>> Announcer: From the Library
of Congress in Washington DC.
>> Harrison Smith: It is
my great pleasure today
to introduce Aaron Becker the
writer of a wonderful series
of wordless picture books that
began in 2013 with "Journey."
Not only was it the
first book in a series,
it was also Aaron's first book and
earned a Caldecott honor in 2014.
The New York Times critic
Sarah Harrison Smith --
the other Harrison Smith -- called
it a masterwork in her review.
Not a bad debut.
The book tells a story of a lonely
girl with a magical red marker.
She draws her way from
a drab sad-looking city
to a brightly colored world
of castles and warriors
and a friendly purple bird.
At the flick of her marker, she can
draw a portal, a boat, a balloon,
a flying carpet, and bring
all these things into life.
The series continued with "Quest,"
which Kirkus Reviews described
as a wordless testament to the power
of not just imagination
but art itself.
And with "Return," which
came out just last month.
Before working with ink and
watercolor in his journey books,
Aaron was actually a film designer.
He did backgrounds, buildings,
and other elements for movies,
including Cars, Monster
House, the Polar Express,
Beowulf, and A Christmas Carol.
Again, there will be time
for questions after the talk,
and I should add that anyone who
has a question will be filmed
for the Library of
Congress's archives.
Aaron's also going to be signing
books today, from 1:30 to 2:30.
Again, please join me in welcoming
Aaron Becker to the stage.
[ Applause ]
>> Aaron Becker: Thank
you, thank you.
How's everybody doing this morning?
All right.
Well, we're going to be
telling some stories today,
but also have a chance to kind
of look underneath the cover
to see how I make these books
and what they're all about.
How many of you by show of hands
have ever read "Journey" before?
Okay, so we've got
some fans here today.
That's fantastic.
We're going to run through
"Journey" kind of quickly.
We're going to do the Reader's
Digest version of the book,
because I really want to have
some time today to talk more
about what goes behind the making of
these books as well as get a chance
to share with you "Return," which
has just come out last month.
This series of books is something I
started when my daughter was born,
about 6 1/2 years ago now.
So this is been my life for the last
six years, and to wait this long
to finally share this final
chapter with everybody,
it's been a lesson
in patience for sure.
But it's been worth the wait.
I'm really excited about
how this story has ended
and the reception it's gotten.
I've been out touring
the country this week.
I was in Texas earlier this
week, and Georgia before that.
I'll be heading to
Minneapolis and Chicago.
And everywhere I go, I talk to
librarians, teachers, and schools
and students, of course,
about these books.
And it amazes me wherever I
go, the children just get it.
They understand what
to do with these books.
It's we adults who've crossed
over that bridge to the other side
of grown-up-dom that have
forgotten how to just be open
to telling stories
with our imagination.
The children really know how to do
it, and they pick out things inside
of these books that I haven't
even noticed yet after living
with these books for six years.
I'll give you an example.
When I was in Georgia, there was
a girl who was four years old,
and she asked, "Why does the
emperor, -- there's an emperor,
a bad emperor on this ship --
"Why does the emperor want to
cage this beautiful purple bird?"
And what I do when I
tell stories to a group
of children is I don't
tell them answers.
I just ask them questions,
which is really the key
to a wordless picture book if you're
reading to a child as a grown-up,
or even if you're a kid and
you're reading that for yourself.
Ask questions.
So what I did is I asked her,
"Well, what do you think?"
And you know what she said?
She said, "Well, I think that the
Emperor is capturing the purple bird
because he must be afraid of it.
He must be afraid of
this purple bird.
And I thought that is amazing.
That never occurred to me what
a great idea, that of course,
of course, we want to put in a cage
the things we don't understand.
And books are a great way to help
us become exposed to the things
around us that maybe
we've never seen before.
I think that's why this
particular story might be
so powerful, is that
it is a journey.
It's a journey into the realm of our
imagination, to explore the limits
of what might be possible.
So let's start with "Journey."
Right away on the cover,
we see a girl.
She's going towards a castle.
She's in a red boat.
We're not sure what's happening.
So you ask a question
-- "Who is she?
Why is she there?
What's she going to do?
Well, we start off back home,
and there she is on her scooter.
She's back home, a little sad now.
And right away, without words,
we know how she's feeling.
We know how she's feeling
because we're human beings,
and we have a language
that's universal.
It's called body language.
And when you see someone, you
know how they're feeling just
by the way they're
holding their bodies.
So she must be feeling sad,
lonely, bored, any number of things.
I'll even ask a child, "How
do you know she's feeling sad,
lonely, and bored?"
Well, they'll explain
about how she's sitting.
And then I'll say, "Well,
why do you think she's sad?"
Again, with no words, they know.
Well, because the other kids won't
play with her, or she's lonely.
She doesn't have any friends.
I haven't told anyone that, but
the child will figure it out.
She goes into her house.
Her mom and dad are
too busy to play.
So she finds this red
marker on her floor.
Again, the red marker, is
it a marker, is it chalk,
is it an oil pastel,
a piece of crayon?
Maybe a colored pencil?
This is also what I do, is
I ask a group of children --
I tell them, "I know the right
answer, and I will tell you."
Well, every child wants to be right.
"Oh, I know, it's a
crayon it's a crayon.
I know he's going to say crayon."
I say, "Look inside your head.
Close your eyes, and I want
you to imagine what it is
that she's drawing with."
And then I say, "Whatever
is inside your head,
that is the right answer."
She draws her door, and through the
door she goes to a magical realm.
This is the beginning of the story.
This is the very beginning.
She's in this magical fantasy realm,
this castle with waterways
instead of roads.
There's even a story
about this castle.
You see, a long time ago this
castle was inherited by a king,
a young king, and this king wanted
to do a very good job being a king.
It was very important to him that he
do a better job than his own father.
He wanted to make sure that everyone
in his kingdom understood
the importance
of kindness, but he wasn't sure.
"As a king, how do I teach this?"
So he would go down to
the water every day.
You see, his castle was
located right by the ocean.
And he would look out over the water
and watch the sunrise every morning.
It was a time for him to think.
It was a time for him to think,
because all day he was
very busy in meetings.
He looked out over the water.
And one day as the sun was
rising, he saw something.
He saw something, something in
the water, something splash.
And it came closer and closer.
It disappeared.
So the next day, he went
back down to the water again
and he watched the sunrise.
And he was looking this
time, not for the sun,
but for something in the water.
And soon enough, it emerged again
and it swam closer and closer,
until finally out from the
water popped a mermaid.
And it was no ordinary mermaid.
You see, this mermaid
was also a young queen.
She had just inherited
the kingdom under the sea.
And she too wanted to do
a good job as a queen.
So they talked for a
while, and they realized,
"Perhaps we can join our
kingdoms together and work
to make this world a better place."
But there was a problem.
You see, the king, while
he was a good swimmer,
could not hold his breath
and live under the ocean.
And the mermaid, well,
she didn't have feet.
She couldn't walk on land.
She couldn't go to the castle.
So the king brought his
people down the next day.
He had an idea.
He said, "Bring your shovels
down to the water's edge,
and I want you to start
digging a hole.
Dig a hole from here to there.
And they dug, and they dug, and
they dug, and they dug all day long,
until they reach the castle.
And when they reached the
castle wall -- thump --
they hit the castle wall.
They looked at the
king for instructions.
He said, "Okay, take
down the castle wall."
They said, "What?
We can't take down the castle wall.
If we take down the castle
wall, then we won't be safe.
We need that wall."
He said, "No, no, no.
For now, don't worry about it.
Just take it down."
They took down the castle wall
then they hit Main Street.
And they looked for
him for guidance.
He said, "Now, what I want
you to do is keep digging.
Dig up all of Main Street."
They thought their king had lost his
mind, but they trusted him for now.
And they dug and they
dug and they dug
until they hit the other
end of the castle wall.
And they looked the
king for instructions.
He said, "Now I want you to
dig up all the alleyways,
and when you reach the end of the
alleyways, dig up all the staircases
that lead up to the upper levels
of this castle and kingdom.
Until we are done, I want
every single bit of road
in this castle dug up,
even the sidewalks."
And that's what they did.
The final day, they came down to
the water's edge with their shovels.
And I don't know if you've
ever been to the beach before,
but when you're playing in the
ocean and you've dug your tunnels,
what happens when you finally
connect it to the waves?
Well, of course, the water rushes
in, and that's just what happened.
The water rushes in.
It hit the castle wall.
It kept going down Main
Street, filled the alleyways,
filled the staircases, until
the entire castle was filled
with water with a canal system.
Now, the mermaid could come
and join him at the castle.
And that is why this castle
has waterways instead of roads.
This one little story,
well, it's in my mind.
But a child can look at this book
in a wordless picture book and make
up all sorts of stories like this.
It's up to you to decide what's
happening behind the scenes.
The girl goes to the castle.
She draws her way through.
She eventually finds herself in
the sky in a red hot air balloon,
and that's where she discovers the
caged purple bird who she rescues.
Flies back home through a
purple door at the bottom
of a palm tree, where a boy awaits.
Now, at the very beginning of
the story when she was lonely
and we saw the other children
playing right there on the street --
Well, the boy, actually was standing
there if you look in the book.
And up in the sky, the
purple bird was flying away.
Sometimes the things we're looking
for are right in front of us.
They draw two circles.
He happens to have his own
purple magic drawing implement.
And they draw a bike.
So that was the end of "Journey."
That was the first book.
But by the time "Journey"
was even published,
I had finished the drawings
for "Quest," and it picks
up right where we leave off.
This time, they go on a
much bigger adventure.
You see, in "Journey"
it was sort of the realm
of a young child in the imagination.
Everything was happening, but
yet there was no real danger.
She was always going to be okay.
In "Quest," things get pushed up
just a notch to the realm of getting
to be an older kid, where suddenly
you might have some responsibility
in this world.
You see, now the castle is on fire,
and the king has given them a map.
This map holds clues to
their adventure ahead.
They realize there's more than just
a red and a purple drawing implement
in this realm with magic.
There are other colors as well.
They go on a quest to
find them under the ocean.
Why, this might be the
mermaid's underwater kingdom.
Who knows?
Into the jungle to a mountain.
Just as they're about
to be caught --
They've collected all the markers.
The purple bird flies away.
It paints a rainbow across
the sky, saves the kingdom
and the king, who's been captured.
And they come back home
after a great celebration,
which ends "Quest."
I also tell children here --
The imagination, it may not
seem like it's a real thing.
It might seem like it's
something we just do for play.
But actually, the imagination
is real, because when we go out
and we pretend that
we're a fast runner,
or we pretend that
we can be an artist,
or we pretend that we can glide
across the sky on the back
of a Pegasus, a small little part of
that play, it ends up inside of us.
It does, it really does.
It ends up inside of us, and
one day it can become real.
That's how we use our imagination
to manifest what we might
want to become one day.
And just as his children might
have painted a rainbow in a land
of make-believe, by the
time they came home,
that rainbow had followed them.
It was no longer raining.
And this leaves us off, right in
time, for the final chapter in the
"Journey" trilogy, "Return."
[ Music ]
All righty, so here we are, back
into the magical world of "Journey."
Now, we see the girl
running through the door.
This time she's just
not walking through
and looking at it with amazement.
She knows where she's
going this time.
She has a purpose.
She's ready for adventure.
The king drew her and the boy an
orange crown at the end of "Quest"
to welcome them into this land.
So she's wearing it on her head.
But let's take a step back.
The story begins right
where "Journey" did.
She's still hoping that
dad will play with her.
He's busy.
He's an architect drawing
at his table.
She draws another red door.
She's given up.
But dad notices this time.
He sees her kite.
He follows her down to her bedroom,
looks through her magic door,
and follows her into
the magical realm.
In "Journey," the girl draws
a red boat by this dock.
Now, she's left a ball there
for the father to find,
or maybe she just left
it there by accident.
Who knows?
He sees it.
And as he gets onto the dock, a
dragon boat appears around the bend
in the river, a glowing,
green-eyed dragon boat.
Perhaps it's evil.
But the father has no choice.
He has to find his daughter.
He jumps aboard and makes
his way to the castle.
He sees her off in the distance
crossing the bridge on her red boat.
By the time he catches up to her,
well, she doesn't want to see him.
Number one, he wouldn't
play with her.
Number two, "This is my turf.
This is my imagination.
You don't belong here, dad."
There's no time to argue.
For those familiar
with ancient history,
you might know something
about a Trojan horse.
Well, this dragon boat is
no ordinary dragon boat.
It is a Trojan dragon boat.
And inside of its hull was hiding
the emperor and his henchmen.
They run towards our heroes.
The king grabs his orange
marker and draws a sword.
But the emperor is smart.
You see, he's been duped by
these kids too many times.
He's been tricked by them with
their magic drawing implements.
So he's come with a plan.
He's created something
out of technology,
something like a magic eraser.
He cranks the box.
It sucks up all the colored
objects, the sword, the crayons.
The boy and the girl
still have theirs.
The boy, who's always
drawing animals --
purple ones, for that matter --
he draws a beast that is half lion
and half eagle, a griffin.
Well, the emperor was
thinking ahead.
He wasn't going to
be fooled this time.
When he built his dragon boat,
he made sure that it had wings.
And he follows them and he
starts to crank his machine --
sucking up the purple
marker, the griffin,
and our heroes fall through the sky.
The boy manages to catch
a hold of the king's hand.
But the girl and her father
fall, fall, fall into the ocean.
The girl has her magic drawing
implement, and she starts
to draw a giant shampoo bottle.
No -- If you remember from
the trailer, the animation,
you'll remember it's a submarine.
And when you get a chance to look
at the book, you look closely,
you'll see the purple bird even
has her own little earphones on,
and she's listening to the
sonar -- boop, boop, boop --
until they find a sea cave.
On the walls of the sea cave are
drawings, petroglyphs in fact,
that tell an ancient story, a myth
about a land with the red balloon
and a purple rhinoceros
and a rainbow
and a dragon boat and
a red submarine.
Why in fact, this story on
the walls tells the past,
it tells the present, but
it also tells a prophecy
of what's yet to come.
And the girl looks up and she
sees a character painted much
like her father with a pocket.
The dad always has a
pocket in his shirts
in which he's always
putting his work markers in.
And the dad's, like, "Me?"
Now, as the shadow of the dragon
boat approaches, the dad thinks,
"Perhaps I can learn
something from my daughter."
Perhaps the word "return" isn't
the return of the girl to her land,
but the return of the father
to his own imagination.
The girl can't believe her eyes.
"What is happening?
Dad has an imagination?"
He's drawing something for the bird.
She's not sure what.
Well, it turns out dad's
pretty clever after all.
As the emperor runs up, he
sucks up the purple bird.
But just as he steps onto the
platform, the doors close.
It's a trap.
He's in a cage.
He drops his box.
But dad picks it up, lifts it up
over his head, and when he throws it
onto the ground, all of
the colors are released.
The animals are free.
The purple bird is free.
Even the griffin is free.
It picks up the caged
emperor, flies away.
Now, all along in this cave, for
those of us who are very observant,
perhaps you've noticed a small door.
Perhaps you've noticed even
on the first page of the book,
a small door somewhere
else in the story.
And out from this small
door is peaking a red kite.
And that is the end of the trilogy.
Thank you guys very much.
[ Applause ]
We have five minutes left.
I know it's not a lot of time.
I have a few slides in
another presentation
that I can show you just
while I'm talking about some
of the things I do to make the book.
But are there any immediate
questions out there?
Yes, ma'am?
>> Question from audience:
Are there any plans
to make animated films
from these books?
>> Aaron Becker: Are there any plans
to make animated films
from this book?
So the trailers that you see
are things that I did myself.
Because I worked in animation,
I know a few things about how
to build things in 3-D and make
camera moves and create some motion.
But I would like to see
"Journey" on a big screen.
I do have a background in cinema,
and I think that would be fantastic.
I can't say anything about it
at this time, but let's just say
that wheels are turning
on the West Coast.
So we'll have to wait.
Yes?
>> Question from audience: For
your third book, did you write it
about a girl bonding with
her dad because you wanted
to bond with your daughter?
>> Aaron Becker: Oh, my goodness.
You're killing me.
Did you just draw a dagger with
your magic drawing implement?
I think so, for sure.
It made a big difference
for writing this story.
Although I had planned out the
entire story when I started
"Journey," and I always her
to be met by her family.
Originally, the mom and the dad
and her sister were going to come
and follow her into the realm.
But wordless picture books,
you have to be very careful,
and only tell a few
things at a time.
So I picked one of them,
and I did pick the dad,
and I think maybe you're right.
While I was working on "Return,"
I lived in Spain with my family.
In a couple weeks, if you go onto my
website, we're going to have a video
up there about my experiences
in Spain.
If you go to storybreathing.com,
it will be posted there.
And it tells a little bit more about
my experiences with my daughter,
working on this book in a
foreign land where I was trying
to learn Spanish and also trying to
paint at the same time and be a dad.
Yes, sir?
>> Question from audience: Why
don't you put words in your books?
>> Aaron Becker: So what happened --
Some of these slides that you've
seen actually maybe I can even
go backwards.
These were the first
drawings that I did.
There about this big.
They're just two-inch little
pencil sketches on paper.
I'm sure you have pencil and paper.
You can do the same thing.
And I had sketched out the whole
story, and by the time I came
to the end of the story,
well, I went back to put words
because books have
words in them, right?
And I realized, "Wait a
minute, the story's been told.
The only thing I can do is
repeat myself at this point."
And that is actually how "Journey"
became a wordless picture book.
It was not an intentional
plan on my part.
It just happened that way
organically, or maybe be magically.
Yes, miss?
>> Question from audience:
How did you make
up the idea to write the story?
>> Aaron Becker: The idea
came from a drawing that I did
that you've seen up
here just a second ago.
I'll go back to it.
From this castle -- I
drew this castle one day,
and it had a little boat in it
with a kid going up to the castle.
And I didn't have a story.
We're going to have to wrap up now,
but just one last thought here.
This is the close-up
of that drawing.
And children at home, if you're
feeling like you're a little scared
of drawing, maybe you don't
feel like you can draw as well
as you can, just remember every
drawing begins with one line.
And if you look very closely at my
drawings, you'll see they're nothing
but one line added to one
line added to one line.
And I'm going to scoot ahead and
just show the young children here
that long ago when I was a
child, I made my own books.
Almost there -- Oh, maybe not.
Come on. Wow, I'm show you
lots of fun stuff here.
Oh, there she is.
There she is.
There we are in Spain.
I learned to draw from this
gentleman, Ed Emberley.
In this was me.
So remember, you can do it too.
Make your own books.
Thank you guys, so much.
I had a great time.
[ Applause ]
>> Announcer: We have
one comment, please.
>> Question from audience: Say,
"We would like to invite
you to come to our school."
>> Question from audience:
We would like to invite you
to come to our Potomac School.
>> Aaron Becker: Oh, you know what?
I was at the Potomac
School, but I didn't get
to -- Are you in kindergarten?
I only got to meet the second and
the third and the fourth graders.
But they have copies of
my book in the library.
You're really a lucky kid because
you have an amazing school,
and you have quite a
journey ahead of you there.
>> Question from audience:
Were you there recently?
>> Aaron Becker: I
was there yesterday.
>> Question from audience:
Her teacher was talking
about you yesterday.
>> Aaron Becker: Oh, okay.
Fantastic.
Thank you.
>> Announcer: This has
been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at LOC.gov.